tous les prix que nous avons payés tous les
sacrifices que nous avons faits Je crois que nous l'avons
fait
Je sais que je
[Musique]
au milieu de la
guerre en Irak quand tant d'autres Américains
manifestaient j'ai bu  le kool-aid
et j'ai dit que j'allais m'engager dans l'
armée américaine je n'ai pas choisi l'armée de l'air je n'ai pas
choisi la marine j'ai dit que je voulais essayer les
forces spéciales
[musique]
je connaissais les risques quand je  s'est présenté et
si j'étais seulement à l'aise si je ne me
préoccupais que de ma propre sécurité, de mon propre
avenir, je n'aurais jamais quitté Hawaï Je
travaillerais encore à la NSA aujourd'hui
[Musique]
vous ne pouvez pas vous opposer à l'
intelligence la plus puissante du monde
agences et être complètement à l'abri des
risques car il y a des adversaires si puissants
que personne ne peut s'y opposer de manière significative
s'ils veulent vous avoir,
ils vous auront à temps, mais en même
temps, vous devez déterminer
ce qui est important pour  vous
[Musique]
la vie des gens est en danger ici à cause
des données que mr.  Snowden a volé donc
les dégâts et leur ampleur n'ont pas
encore été mesurés
[Musique]
la principale chose à retenir ici est que
je n'ai pas choisi de destination particulière
J'essayais d'aller en Amérique latine pour
demander l'asile en vertu du droit des droits de l'homme
qui est  bien établi,
malheureusement, j'ai été gelé en
transit par le Département d'État
une fois qu'ils ont appris que j'avais quitté Hong
Kong, il y avait une rumeur selon laquelle mon
passeport avait été en quelque sorte annulé avant mon
départ, ce n'est pas vrai. J'aimerais
retourner aux États-Unis.  c'est le
but ultime, mais si je dois passer
le reste de ma vie en prison, la seule
exigence fondamentale sur laquelle nous devons tous nous mettre d'
accord est qu'au moins j'obtienne un
procès équitable et c'est la seule chose que le
gouvernement  a refusé de garantir
parce qu'ils ne donneront pas accès à
ce qu'on appelle une défense d'intérêt public
[Musique]
il n'y a aucune preuve publique qu'un
individu a subi un préjudice en conséquence
et nous savons qu'il n'y a aucune
preuve classifiée qu'un individu  a subi un
préjudice en conséquence ou nous
l'aurions vu il y a des années aurait fait la
une de tous les journaux du
monde Je suis à l'aise avec les décisions que
j'ai prises mais je ne pense pas que ce soit à moi
de décider de la  direction de l'avenir de
notre société,
vous